so we went to a Nintendo switch event
over the weekend and obviously there's
been a bunch of first party games but
there's also been a ton of third-party
support which is lovely to see and we
tucked into a few of those games which
ones were your favorite I really liked
sonic mania I got to play sonic mania
and Sonic was the first video game that
I ever played and sonic mania feels like
an old-school sonic yeah and I got to
play it I think I played it in handheld
mode so that's with the to Joy cons on
either side of a switch screen and it
played fantastically the new d-pad
though which is just four buttons
instead of being a traditional you know
cross d-pad felt a little strange to get
used to yeah but the analog stick works
great it looks like sonic it feels like
sonic and it plays really really well
and that's something that I can see
playing on the train I'm a switch
definitely what about you well we also
both tucked into justins which we we did
play just dance in a crowded Hall I
played on the wii u a few times and we
played on the playstation it feels just
like just as it's just ants one of the
things I would commend it for though is
those joy calm controllers are tiny yes
um so you can hold it yeah and because
I've played just dance with a wiimote a
move controller and a phone yeah and the
joy con seems perfect yes dance cuz it's
so small easy to hold it's great I
likely to end up throwing at your TV
totally totally and then after we ship
we play just dance we played a racing
game called fast rmx which is basically
what looks a lot like f-zero will wipe
out and I really enjoyed it what did you
think well one of the things I really
liked is that it has along with all the
other things you have to think about
like acceleration and various been
breaking and banking you need to use
Bruce blaze by making sure that your car
is the same color yes Elaine yeah
suicide the orange or blue I thought
that was really cute and it's something
that I was aware of as i was playing in
folsom yeah another thing you have yeah
you have when you're trying to get to
the front of the pack so I steadily fell
backwards and back as I was like oh well
least I'm blue while I'm on the blue
boost lane even though I was you know
forgetting to you accelerate and boost
and get in front of people and do all
the other things yeah I I I really
enjoyed it up it was great and we got to
play on the new Pro controllers as well
which feel quite quite
so I thought so you also play bomberman
i did and i am still apparently terrible
at bomberman and it was so it was for
player and I was the last one to turn up
there were three people there already be
go right and they didn't have a joy con
ready for me and the dude had to sink it
and he got to show me how you sink your
icons which is really cool it's just you
slotted into the side of screen then you
pull back out and you've got your
control and I thought that was really
cool but yeah it's it's Bomberman it
looks like Bomberman it plays like
Bomberman it's really fun to play
multiplayer and then so you played
frozen bites new game has been heroes
did it say it's very cool kid actually
it's a strategy like action game with
turn-based gameplay basically you have
three different characters and it's
played with in lanes so you're sort of
finding ways of enemies who are
constantly coming at you and it
surprisingly works really well in the
switch right so um each of your like
letter buttons like XY are associated
with a lane so you can swap characters
in and out of each lane to kind of
figure out who's going to be the best
character to be fighting like whatever
creature is coming at you in each lane
mhm each of the characters have a bunch
of different abilities and spells you
kind of need to figure out what is the
best strategy to attack with it seems
really cool and if you're into being
able to like a bill build a good grief
and like be able to quick change its
lends itself to plays you aren't that
familiar with strategy as well because
it's turn based so you can pause it
constantly okay you can play the game as
fast or as slow as you want depending on
how comfortable you are with switching
lanes and figuring out what the best
tactics are so those are just some of
the third-party games that we were able
to get hands on with now that are coming
to switch obviously there's a bunch more
can be great to see things like skyrim i
think one of the things that's
interesting at is that a lot of these
third-party games are running just a lot
like they run on every other platform
that you can find them on yeah they're
not the kind of one to switch type games
that are like a gimmicky and really
taking advantage of all the very
specific nuances of the hardware what
they're running quite well so yeah I
think at this point it'll just be
interesting to see whether
to go from you